Palestinian leader Mahmoud Abbas was
warmly welcomed in Beijing when he met
president Xi Jinping Abbas is the first
Arab leader to visit China this year
Beijing says it wants to play an active
role in promoting peace between
Palestine and Israel the two sides
marked the visit by announcing a
strategic partnership
China is one of the first countries to
recognize the Palestine Liberation
Organization and the state of Palestine
with the personal commitment of
President XI and president Abbas China
Palestine relations has sustained sound
momentum of growth in recent years the
political trance between two countries
has grown the visit comes as China looks
to expand its influence in the Middle
East a region where the presence of the
United States has waned in recent years
U.S led israel-palestine talks have been
deadlocked since 2014.
on Wednesday she put forward a
three-point peace proposal it includes
the establishment of an independent
Palestinian State bolstering economic
aid and convening a peace conference
I think China is just stepping up and
initiating China has high economic
stakes in the region China is emerging
as uh as a global leader in factors that
are of interest to the Middle Eastern
region as well and I think we've seen a
gradual change in the perceptions about
China in March Beijing successfully
brokered a reproachment between Saudi
Arabia and Iran ending a seven-year
diplomatic Rift it's trying to do the
same between Ukraine and Russia
assigning an Envoy to push for dialogue
to end the war but little progress has
been made with neither side willing to
see territory Beijing wants to portray
itself as a global Peacemaker and a
reliable partner that understands the
needs of developing countries meeting
with mahurapas is an opportunity for Xi
Jinping to increase his clout in the
Middle East expanding Chinese influence
and investment
at a conference in Riyadh this week
Business Leaders signed 30 deals with
more than 10 billion dollars China is
already the Region's biggest buyer of
crude oil and is looking to build new
infrastructure as part of its Belton
Road initiative but not everyone is
happy Washington has warned that
beijing's growing influence poses a
threat to the rule-based international
order Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing